hi thanks thanks for having me I i'm
here today to talk a little bit about
the apache system ml project which is an
open source project from the IBM
Research Group so I'm a member of the
spark Technology Center in San Francisco
I'm speaking on behalf of the system ml
team so I'm a member of the STC
development and applications team i'm in
charge of outreach and things things
along those lines and we have a system
ml team who's been a development core
that has been working on this for
several years of which Fred rice is the
chief architect and a member of the IBM
Academy of Technology so I want to make
sure i'm representing the system ml
group as well as the spark Technology
Center let's see so so just a brief
description of what the spark Technology
Center is just a brief show of hands who
has heard of spark and used it in
applications ok great so it's getting
its getting a lot of getting a lot of
adoption this day these days so 2015 of
June IBM announced a major commitment to
the apache spark project it was already
growing exponentially and then we just
sort of increased that growth by by
getting getting involved and in doing so
we have about a hundred contributors to
the apache spark project we have three
committers one of them is a spark SQL
committer another one is a machine
learning library committer and the other
one is a spark whose streaming committer
and during the time that we announced
our commitment to the spark technology
center we released this project called
Apache system ml to sort of show our
support for the group this has been an
internal project and we released the
entire project is it open source and so
IBM has a long history of doing things
like this if you recall the Eclipse
project and some of the other ones they
release massive massive projects is open
source project
and it was a founding member of the amp
lab and it was also founding member of
scala center and other partnerships as
open source partnerships such as our
studio and other partnerships so so our
mission really is to contribute to the
spark community in every way we can
conceive of and we want to we want to
expand the core technology to make it
enterprise and cloud ready so pretty
much every all of our we not only have
an open source footprint but all of our
products are now being migrated over to
spark so spark is pretty much the de
facto runtime for for everything now so
so we have some we are going to
accelerate the business value we want to
build data science skills to drive
intelligence into business applications
and what this means is outreach we just
want to make sure that everybody has
good access to training materials and
can learn how to use spark and free and
download it have access to the big data
university project we participate
heavily in meetups and the other the
other form of out rates that I'm getting
more and more interested in is is
outreach into academic communities
because they don't always have as much
access to the big data tools and we'd
like to get people coming out of
graduate school with these with these
transferable skills that will allow them
to to find to find work more easily and
and we think the spark is the is going
to be even more of a standard at moving
forward so some of the focus areas are
machine learning and this is always kind
of a fine point if you're familiar with
the spark project there's ml lib which
is the machine learning library which is
the which is the spark library that you
can load and have access to all the
machine learning functions and then
there's system ml and we'll go into what
system ml is in in detail here today and
and system ml is sort of a separate
open-source project that connects to
spark you can launch a spark instance
and have access to system ml and then
there's the spark and our project and
there are many many incarnations of
of our connecting to spark the most
notable is the spark our project that
comes as part of the spark core so
there's a there's a huge huge effort in
machine learning and IBM is right now
the number one contributor to the
machine learning library in addition to
developing the system ml project we have
spark SQL standardization as well and
then we also are bringing spark SQL up
to the ANSI standards we're also testing
and making shirts performing on par with
traditional database traditional
database servers and the the take-home
message with with spark SQL is if you
can possibly put any of your work load
into spark SQL you're going to get
immediate immediate speed up with it we
have a streaming project our contributor
is in Bangalore and he's developed he
they actually founded an entire spark
technology center around this committer
so one second here and so we have a
committer in Bangalore working on the
spark technology center centered around
streaming there and we also want to
provide application support and what
that means is we want to help we want to
help people who are who are trying to
write new code or trying to migrate a
MapReduce code into a new environment
we'd like to help we help clients we
also want to reach out to academic
institutions and help them write
application level spark code so
basically lots and lots of lots of
outreach today I wanted to talk about
specifically the system ml project and
this this project has actually been
around for a very very long time at IBM
in 2007 there were just a whole
hodgepodge of projects that basically
had machine learning maybe in 2007 I'm
not sure if we were calling it machine
learning it was you know statistical
modeling around a whole variety of
projects that were either research-based
or
or had a there was some client that was
interested in some statistical modeling
application in 2009 they formed a team
for a scalable machine learning library
and this was at the time they were
committed to running it on Hadoop but
even at that time they knew that while
Hadoop was the sort of de facto standard
there was going to be another it would
be very likely that it would be another
standard that would emerge so you'll see
that in some of the design by 2009 and
2010 they were talking to clients
building consortiums and trying to
figure out what kind of problems that
they were encountering in 2011 2014 I
would say was really cave time right
they really just dug in and did the work
and wrote the code and you know made
this work on some of their applications
this actually wound up being the
underpinnings of a project that they had
that was called big R which was
essentially a scalable our package that
was available at the time and then 2
2015 is when they really stepped into
the open source community with it during
that entire time they made the
announcement in June by the time of June
2016 it's got a its second release and
it's got a beautiful website if you ever
get a chance to check it out so so with
all of that the things that they notice
were that there were lots of changes in
features data size and really the desire
to customize the algorithm it didn't
matter how complete the library was how
many algorithms were available there was
always a sense of I want to tweak this
here I want to do this and I always want
to do it at a algorithmic level and I
don't have a black box library that just
returns results and I can't I don't know
how to interpret it or you know I don't
know how to improve it if I want to come
up with something new and they want to
be able to iterate through this cycle
very very quickly and so this was
starting to emerge as a sort of domain
specific machine learning idea right
very each each domain had its own set of
issues that really new algorithms came
out of those new set of issues it wasn't
one algorithm that really solved every
problem for them and so you can imagine
this this data scientist picture that
you have where you have a data scientist
who is usually an expert in in our or
Python or possibly other ones just
curiosity who who is the are we had we
have sort of our Python type folks here
or okay so folks who really like to use
are as they're sort of go to language if
they're noodling something out what
about Python okay great well that's it's
like it's the Python api's are better to
for spark so and so the idea was you
know you go to your you pick your go-to
language the one that you really feel
comfortable and sort of developing and
noodling things out and you go to your
personal computer and you have your data
that sits on your laptop essentially
because that's the one that you can
carry around you can have it with you at
all times and you really get a deep
understanding of this data in your
personal computer and then as soon as
you need to scale it up your your host
right you're you really you're having
trouble migrating the data to a cluster
you've got a whole different set of
tools that you're trying to to use to
analyze these things and you no longer
have that deep understanding if not only
the language but the data right so that
it's not only the understanding of the
data that drives this but but also the
language that you're used to using and
plotting so this you know this wine this
when you when you're trying to migrate
this to your big data workload this take
date days or weeks and there's errors
there's lots of errors that are
introduced and so if you go into maybe
if you go into a work environment you
typically have the data science crew and
you've got the data engineering crew and
you're sort of tossing your algorithm
over the fence and hoping that it gets
implemented the way you would and
dissipated maybe you can provide some
tests or something like that yeah this
was much more the case with you had the
Hadoop programmer because it was a
pretty heavy lift to get
these algorithms into a Hadoop Hadoop
workflow I'd say this this barrier to
entry is is much less now with spark I
think spark is much easier to write and
I think there are even cases where you
can wear both hats and be the the data
scientist and and the spark programmer
but there are still fine points that you
have to address on both sides of this
right you have to you have to tune your
algorithm as a data scientist but you
also have to tune the cluster as an
engineer so there's still it's not a
complete it's not a complete complete
bridge and then of course there's some
really old school paradigms with mpi
programs so if you really wanted to
turbo it out you can do you know MPI and
f 90 years or C++ or something and and
those those those still work because you
still have you still got performance
issues and those are the you know you
certainly going to run run with those so
but but with all of that you know really
what you want is is you just want to you
want to write something you wanted to
have you basically want it to look the
same on your laptop as it does in the
big data world and this is this is also
true for for spark if you write your
right your spark code on your laptop
it'll look the same it pretty much as
you run it on your cluster although
there are some tuning issues you have to
address we have another system ml layer
that will give you another layer of
abstraction and so this will give you
another another way to sort of cycle
through this so you can cycle through it
on your laptop it look pretty much the
same when you run it on your big cluster
and additionally it'll do some
additional optimization so it'll it'll
well with a spark you've got to count
your partitions and make sure you've got
the exact you've got to do all this
stuff with the with system amela has a
little bit more cost based optimization
built into it for example you define a
matrix it's dense matrix or it's a
sparse matrix you don't have to keep
track of you know certainly a dense
matrix multiplies differently than a
sparse matrix but you don't have to keep
track of that you just you just define
your matrices in it manages all of the
it takes care of all the memory
management all that kind of stuff for
you so it you know it gives you it gives
you it gives you allows you to iterate a
little bit faster so there's one
layer of tuning that you don't have to
worry about as much so you get fast
iteration and so so these are the
requirements that they came up with to
support this idea of a domain-specific
you basically want to have a high-level
semantic attached to a low-level runtime
and I'll show you I'll show you a little
bit about what that what that means
certainly you want flexibility you want
to be able to retool your algorithms is
needed the data independence I was
talking to you about with the dent with
the dense versus the sparse matrices
there's other other instances of that
and of course the scale independence
right it runs it runs everywhere and so
the system ml approach has these high
language high level language front ends
so I haven't shown you the syntax yet
but I'll show it to you in the next
slide but the idea is that you have a
something that is completely agnostic to
to the runtime and everything else and
that it for the most part right now we
have something that is an hour like
language that's really the primary one
we have a Python like numpy like
language that you can write these
expressions in and I'm always trying to
push them to do to develop a matlab
language but i don't know if there's
enough interest for that and the are
like language looks pretty much the same
so but that language will go into what's
called the high level operations this
will parse the language out it will also
create a series of instructions that
will optimize the directed acyclic graph
that's completely independent of the
runtime and then it will pass it into a
low-level a set of low level level
operations and this was built into it
again you recall this project has
persisted through several runtimes now
it started out on the Hadoop runtime and
now it runs on a spark runtime so this
whole idea of separation of high level
operations and low level operations was
to allow the project to persist through
many generations of frameworks and so
these low-level operations essentially
it'll take all of that and it will
translate it into a series of spark
command
or whatever the next generation of stuff
is so throughout all of this it's got
cost based optimization built into it so
and I'll show you some examples of it
it'll it'll do some algebra algebra
economization and then it will also do
lots of hardware optimizations so just
an example here this is a this is a
matrix division if you just focus on
this is the are like syntax the
transpose times V divided by W times H
and just a simple optimization shown
here this is kind of what the matrix
looks like this is a this is like a dot
divided where each element is divided by
each other element in the matrix and so
the idea is if you didn't if you weren't
smart about parsing a language you would
you would create this very large
intermediate matrix and then you would
carry that out that know what I would
gobble up a bunch of memory and and but
this this sort of optimization it
recognizes in parenthesis it knows that
it can that operation can operate on it
without ever having to store that
intermediate matrix right so it does
stuff like this which is a you know in a
big data world there aren't
optimizations that really are out there
like this is a sort of a unique
optimization here and so now we can just
compute this matrix directly and so
that's one of the high-level
optimizations right because that's a
that optimization can hit is sort of
independent of runtime you can just
create create any optimization you like
so it has a big it has a big flavor of
the SQL language right i mean it's
essentially a mathematical realization
of the standard query language it has
all these same principles right you have
a complete abstraction of the language
from the hardware and then you have lots
and lots of optimization based on
parsing parsing the language so we can
start with this textbook problem and has
a textbook solution and would you show
that a small tweak would like to
introduce a new algorithm to see to see
how to do the performance and you
realize that you have to go into the
guts of the algorithm in order to write
it and so this is the the product
recommendation problem and so those who
bought this about that and this is the
classic one this is the one that won the
netflix prize alternating least squares
and this is a written in our so you
start with random factors and then you
hold the movies factor constant and then
you think this is conjugate gradient to
solve for the users factor and then you
hold the user's factors solve for the
movies using conjugate gradient so this
is the this is the idea of the
alternating least squares because you
alternate between the two factors to
determine and then rinse and repeat
until you converge and so you know I
guess the point here is this is written
in our this is a pretty pretty easy to
read relatively speaking i still think
matlab is easier to read but that's okay
you know this is pretty pretty good it's
got and and and it's got iterative
algorithms it's got all of that so so
now you now if you want to construct
something called the co purchasing
matrix this one is actually a matrix
completion problem and it's actually
constructed in a slightly different way
and so you how often you buy the product
after you buy the product j populated
with this sparse matrix emily
essentially what you do is you you now
you multiply these two factors to
produce less sparse matrix and new and
basically you sort of populate the
sparse matrix with with new entries and
this is very similar to a transition
matrix or something like this where you
start with a strange sparse transition
matrix and as you iterate through that
trends
it slowly becomes less sparse and so
what this is it essentially a
factorization operation in this is
called the Poisson non-negative matrix
factorization so factorization
algorithms don't appear in a lot of
these scalable platforms just because
they don't have optimal matrix
multiplication procedures so now you
have a whole new class of algorithms
it's actually you know maybe not as
widely known that you can start to use
because you have an efficient engine
that can actually carry out these
calculations and so this one's pretty
straightforward is just lots and lots of
matrix multiplies and and so for the the
particular data set that they studied
they were they were able to show that
the ALS just didn't capture this capture
the random factors or so weren't able to
capture the known values and then when
they ran the are the our algorithm we've
just shown they got much better and
apparently they got all the way up to a
hundred percent which I have to double
check but this is where we normally
bring in a spark expert and so we've
done this before right we find a
successful algorithm particular these
linear algebra problems and and and any
kind any time you're doing linear
operations you're usually even something
as simple as a matrix inversion or
something is several hundred lines of
spark code and spark is designed to be
somewhat elegant language so you can
only imagine how many lines it would be
in Java but but in general you know that
was the workflow even if you come up
with sort of another algorithm that just
requires a few tweaks you're looking at
a few hundred lines of code and and that
is not practical for algorithmic
exploration if you just want to do a
one-off algorithm and see how it works
so that that's not going to work so
essentially this is the same this is the
same one it's basically we've got this
are like syntax it's we've done done our
best to emulate emulate the are our
in taxes a few things that are slightly
different and then there's some course
there's some extra extra sintac
syntactic sugar that they built into it
and so the so so so they are if you're
just running are if you have the number
of products it scales quadratically and
this also scales quadratically it's just
super flat and it's just at the bottom
of the it's just getting ready to just
it's going to take a while before you'll
be able to see the curvature but so so
very performant and it's just is is
because it's optimized for these
particular operations and the result
quality is comparable to the are the
single are instance so so it's a it's
for these kinds of applications it's
we've had we've had great success with
it so you know they get I guess the take
home here is is it just if you find
yourself limited by the canned libraries
and you can't it's hard to get into the
guts of it you might want to consider
system ml as as an option because it's
pretty straightforward if you've got if
you've already got spark running you
basically download the single jar and
you included in the spark shell a man to
launch it and then you have access to
the entire system ml context and then
from that context you can launch all of
these DML scripts I was going to bring
up we've got we've got on the github
account if you jump if you jump on the
count you can see we've got Oh 20 or 30
algorithms that are there currently that
you wouldn't see in say ml lib or some
of the other ones and then you can
download those you or you can actually
just use those if you download the
github and modify those to your more
specific needs and of course you know
the the custom algorithm in our of
course has poor scalability although
just as an aside the new versions of
sparkle allow you to run multiple spar
algorithms in parallel so sometimes that
can that can help you with scaling but
but of course we get we get everything
with with system ml so so it's it's it's
pretty straightforward to to to to get
it to get it to get it incorporated your
workflow so if you can and we've had
this in terms of you know trying to
build scalability into into your
workflow from from the very beginning
you know we've had when we bring in
interns and and folks just getting into
the maybe the research project or
something like that before before we
before they even start to work on you
know their their analytics or they
wanted to exploratory data we set them
up with a cluster immediately
immediately have access to cluster
resources and start and basically a
Python API or some or an our API or
something like that but then you're
immediately working on the cluster right
away because then you have scalability
built sort of right from the get go into
your workflow that way you don't run
into that bottleneck you know we're at
that we're at that point now where we
can sort of you know ask you to start at
this start with scalability as as as an
option so I was going to show go ahead
and get on github and you can take a
look at all of the algorithms can swing
by office hours I have a aplin notebook
with with the linear regression running
and get a feel for what the syntax looks
like and how to how to get it working so
lots and lots of additional material on
it there's a recording but one hour
meetup class we also have an entire
course on on system ml developing
algorithms in system ml and actually
it's a course that we offer over the
summer to students that come to visit at
Alma din research so there's lots of
material out there there's a great this
is a great I think this was the one
where it's the cost based optimization
of the
of the matrix multiplies which is a
really interesting topic and then this
is the source code here at at the Apache
Incubator so so it we're actively
seeking contributors and users so that
means if if if well if your company or
an academic lab and you want to you want
to run any of this stuff we just want to
talk about it so we'd be glad to help
you get it going and and and and then we
just like to see you know basically
we're interested in seeing use cases so
we can get the code in shape and make
sure its performance and all of that so
and also if you want to be a contributor
that would also be great
so this is the this is the core this is
the core research group this is
available if you look up the IBM
research project again this is this is a
very this is this group has been around
for oh gosh yeah maybe 5-10 years so and
here's some more information if you have
any additional questions feel free to
stop by office hours or be happy to
answer any questions at this time if you
have a question raise your hand I'll
come over to you with the microphone
so spark has a new library machine
learning library ml after Emily bright
how does this relate to the Emma library
of the ml pipeline yeah yeah you know
they're pretty much completely distinct
projects so even the ml lib you know all
the data types in the ml lib are
completely different from the system ml
see you can you know you can put you
know it all exists in the same namespace
and they are all cashed in memory and
and so you won't have to write to disk
or anything like that but you have to do
a little bit of wrangling to you know
get get it from one pull data out of FML
lib and put it into system ml or
something like that and that's just you
know just historically they're slightly
different data types but but certainly
you can use all the day once your data
is loaded then you can access it through
as long as you can access it you can you
can run all these algorithms on it so